this is too much
Gallup has been tracking American
attitudes on global warming for more
than two decades in 1997 48 percent
nationally so that the effects of global
warming had already begun in galip's new
March poll 60 percent of that response
just 12 percent so that the effects
would never happen however a majority in
gallops new poll did not believe global
warming would pose a serious threat to
them during their lifetimes that may be
one reason why the issue ranks low when
pollsters asked about top priorities for
the President and Congress in a January
Pew survey 46 percent said that global
climate change should be a top priority
of the 19 issues pew asked about climate
change tied for second to last place
more people 62% said that protecting the
environment should be a top priority
terrorism outstripped both as a top
priority at 73 percent in Gallup polling
the public worries more about
environmental problems they can see in
their own communities such as the
pollution of drinking water than they
worried about climate change are you
concerned about climate change why or
why not
let us know in your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe to more
research and videos from AEI